there they are Julianne and Derek Hough
huff ananda pahto so to speak you like
that in rehearsal and they have come a
long way baby since they made their
debut on Dancing with the Stars it was
seven years ago
no anything since then he's won an Emmy
and she has started with Tom Cruise it
accomplished nothing
then I'm lacquered so the question is
why are they back dancing again well
they invited us over to find out let us
dance
we wanted to be fun and a celebration
every night and it shouldn't feel like
hard work even though it's going to be I
personally can't get enough of this fair
dancing I mean come on let's face it
weren't they your favorite eye candy
ever on Dancing with the Stars but they
also have hot movie careers going so why
I live dance tour we really just kind of
ask each other you know what we love to
do and performing from a live audience
is you know the best thing what we love
that and there's nothing quite like that
we've all seen the adorable home movies
of this pair growing up in competitions
but the sibling rivalry didn't just quit
just because we were there can we change
stools your stool is your stool is
hurting my feelings right now
can i hook on to you can you not doc
this is our biggest fight we've ever had
there move live on tour will feature
dancing and singing but what else and
I'm juggling fire
they might see how really uncool I am
I'll be pretty dorky I think they're
witnessing this right now I think